you know this movie is really racist is
it like the way they just portrayed
black people in this film as Somali yea
Somali and it's like why if you're gonna
make up an ethnicity if it could name at
least you know what I'm talking about
kept in what is happening he's like a
Captain Crunch I want to go get some
brunch I'm Jerry
welcome to reasons to see where we get
your reasons to see I don't think we're
gonna have any but in case not to see
Captain Phillips let's hang out
i razinin see number one captain
phillips kept phillips re there kevin
phillips kevin phillips cap captain
didn't like this movie really should
have been called captain phillips
captain phillips is cool it isn't quite
one of those movies where it's like he's
an ordinary guy and now he's a superhero
he's sort of watching the whole time and
try and come up with ways of sort of
outsmarting these guys tom hanks his
performance in this i I didn't quite get
it when people were like oh it's so
powerhouse this is one of his best of
all time until the end you're gonna tell
you the end right now basically what I
got from it without ruining anything for
you guys is like dies at the end and
then goes on to write the book the movie
is based on yes it's in he is like the
Jesus of our time yeah that's what the
movie that Ghost Rider is about is about
him writing this book after he's dead
yeah and then he also got a motorcycle
and that's what Ghost Rider is about it
is Captain Phillips is that a very
strange afterlife when I was watching it
I suddenly realize like dang this is not
like your typical type of film where
it's like oh we start tough like this
and then he grows and do this whole
other being uh what you really see is
like damn this guy has to live with this
experience either
yeah there's trauma that's gonna like
[ __ ] up with this guy's life for a while
man at the end like you said that was
when I was like holy [ __ ] Tom Hanks like
yeah this is a veneer like this is more
intense than I've seen you in a long
time because it's like Tom Hanks is gold
throughout this is like how long can
captain Phillip to keep his [ __ ]
together even together and try to find
the interesting ways of not giving it
through away it's it's one of those
great like subtle performances where
everything is very internal it's not
like the typical like Academy Award
worthy performance where they're
screaming the whole time like that like
it's it's not glamorous I mean you could
feel what he's feeling without him
having to say things about it he'll be
talking about something you know trying
to convince the Somali pirates about
something but you can tell what's really
going on and in him but I really like
but he's also very believable as he's
trying to convince every moment it's
it's so subtle but it's like the
soundless performances are sometimes the
most tricky yeah because he is
absolutely believable in every single
month it's just he's so authentic that
you don't even think he's acting raising
this seat number two captain Somalia I
am the captain sure sure yeah I'm lucky
I'm look just look at okay I don't know
what you want because there's a whole
15-minute sequence the most confusing in
the film it's when you really understand
the dynamic between captain Phillips and
this guy whose name meant Dino's name I
don't know barkhaa Abdi is the actor's
name and the the character's name is
spelled like Muse but I think they kept
saying Musa yeah this movie really likes
that band a lot oh this guy was cool
I've never seen him in anything before
and he wasn't in a typical villain
because something about him was you know
a little sympathetic which I kinda did
not like at times at times it was like
you seem a little foolish see that was
and I did like that there's a little too
foolish it's like he had this this
quality of like he had so much invested
in what he was doing it's like moments
kept playing out where I'm like you're
not making the best decisions but I
believe in this moment that like I would
follow you if I was your your you know
Lackey they didn't walk away from the
performance thinking about like a couple
of moments but for the most part I did
like him because like he was sympathetic
and at the same time by the same time he
was like he was really sympathetic like
what is this guy's deal you can never
really figure them out they set him up
as if like yours they're setting up a
villain that you're like oh we're gonna
understand what he's doing this but they
didn't really don't do that but for some
reason you walk away feeling like you
kind of understand this guy well you get
because you do get a sense for the fact
that he's from a different part of the
world you know that things just are very
different there so you're negotiating
between first world and third world and
you you get where he's coming from and
why he's doing this
his feels like they they cast like a
real guy who used to do this yeah
exactly like he's so skinny and so like
emaciated looking because that something
about him doesn't strike me as the kind
of guy that was like I want to be an
actor one day it's like he doesn't want
to audition what this headshot reason to
see number three the directing and
cinematography Paul Greengrass must have
like 15 cameras going all the time
because there is so much coverage in his
films and so much like shaky like I
can't zoom straight which is cool but
I'm like how many cameras and camera
operators must he have going at once
what I gotta say about whatever I just
have to say real fast look if there's
something I should say it's gonna be
said right now Paul Greengrass
I love his films I think he's a great
director but I had a hard time being as
engrossed in this one because it was
like it's another Paul Greengrass you
know where it's like super [ __ ]
shaky-cam they're going for kind of that
you're very realistic like someone's you
really watching him recording this the
whole time like he's done that so many
times now you're 1993 the two Bourne
films the Green Zone I think any given
Sunday was sort of to pepper a to do and
now this so I think he just loves doing
that style he's great at it but after a
while it's like it's hard for me to just
get into this now because it's like it
just feels like Paul Greengrass to me
again but I think it works in this movie
especially part look totally you're up
there's my what I said you're on the sea
so like nothing is still anyway
yeah so I feel like that that helps with
everything but it does you know enhance
the just sort of dirty natural you know
feeling of everything it's just it took
me a little while to get into the film
like honestly I wasn't really that into
the film until like that first thing you
see from the trailer when they notice
that Somali pirates are coming after
them that's when I was like I'm starting
getting interested but before that the
so whole hack once said I wasn't a big
fan of okay what's interesting about it
is you realize it is effective when you
take the film as a whole like it does
set the mood for something a little bit
more real and slow because they like
it's just like a commie thing they just
when you're see watching you know
realistic events happen and suddenly
that [ __ ] starts going down and you're
like yeah that feels very real because
Paul Greengrass doesn't what does suck
for me though is I saw the trailer like
a lot the trailer does ruin a lot when
you remember the trailer they're pretty
damn well just because the trailer just
does show a lot it was easy for me to
like oh well I remember what I saw in
the trailer so this thing is probably
gonna happen yeah it was hard for me to
just get engrossed into the moment to
just be a part of the journey because I
couldn't help but like focus on the end
result for some reason there was only
one detail I specifically was like okay
at some point they're gonna have to give
him a lifeboat right that one yeah was
was sort of sticking out especially when
they first showed it in the shot and I
was like oh there it's like just
portraying the realism of what it's like
to be in this situation there are times
there's a pretty [ __ ] scary like your
times like that [ __ ] that guy's gonna
get his head blown off right now [ __ ]
just because because reason to see
number four the music
honestly the music was probably the
first thing that I noticed Rose like
okay I see what people are talking about
there's no music for a while and when
the music comes it's pretty cool you
know like I think they used to music
when they introduced the villain but the
music that that they use to like for
like a lot of the high stakes tension
scenes are is very good it's not
intrusive in the sense that it's not
wall-to-wall music like it comes
now you know an interesting mix of that
sort of fast-paced you know arpeggiated
cynthy stuff and then not cynthy stuff
like pop but you know that and then
mixed in with more tribal you know and
percussive sounds dude I love the tribal
sounds behind the music yeah reason I
see number five the editing
yeah the editing in this film is
impressive because so this is hard to
notice editing just because it's
supposed to look flawless yeah yes but
when I was watching this movie I was
thinking like like what you were saying
earlier there's so much coverage going
through this footage must be [ __ ]
exhausting but this yeah it's like any
plug Greengrass movie I gotta imagine
that it takes a magician to sift through
all that footage just be like this looks
like a movie nominate him Academy of
Motion Pictures science I'm that guy and
that film guy who's like Ryan's
consensus a thrilling yet very realistic
thriller is the reason to see captain
Phillips a thrilling yet realistic
thriller is the reason I see captain
Phillips yeah I think like just that is
the best way for me to describe it and
when you're encompassing all of it
because it is very just real [ __ ]
rules dick Sherri's consensus a gritty
thriller with some good performances is
the reason to see Captain Phillips a
great thriller with some good
performances the reason to see Captain
Phillips Tom Hanks and those guys
playing off each other and you know Paul
Greengrass is general style all that
stuff not meshing together is is you
know what I dug most about this thank
you guys for checking out our show why
don't you go ahead scroll through that
comment box below and tell us what the
[ __ ] did you think of Captain Phillips
and once you're done with that come on
over here and click this button so you
can see more because those are reasons
to see we're up this is real getting
close to 100 or it really that's crazy
yeah and we need more followers that's
all you're gonna like us on
you know follow us on Twitter and then
once you're done with all that good
stuff you're gonna want to get updated
every time a new reviewer video is out
right so so subscribe I thought this
film was gonna make him like an action
hero or something is he's not really an
action hero yeah well he's not really
that like none of his plans really work
although he's backfired
yeah it's like you could really tell
he's grasping for straws most all of
this movie which I thought was
interesting this movie's a good example
of this how when you have like a
protagonist and antagonist who believe
equally in what they're doing and watch
it does two things collide that's what's
up yeah kind of like God in the devil
it's exactly what this movies yeah in a
way exactly let's face it cuz heaven is
the boat heaven is ah that's why I know
made the ark that's right two of every
kind of cargo yeah and yeah the Bible's
racist they don't like blacks some
people might say like Ryan you shouldn't
say that but I'm gonna go on record and
say the Bible is racist against black
people be careful with what you record
and I just look there it's it's it's
there it's all there they specifically
pointed out I'm just kidding God God
likes black people I mean are usually
you made all this stuff yeah I'm gonna
make a whole bunch of things but I only
like the white ones people go we're all
God's children and then I think okay
really think about that for a second
father and son or father and daughter
right why would he ever just why would
you ever end up doing something where
God your father is gonna be like [ __ ]
you I want nothing to do with you
anymore
really he's God he gonna handle anything
so why would he just feel gay dad no son
of mine no son of mine will be a
homosexual think about would you disown
your own son
why would you just send your son as God
doesn't approve what makes you think you
that guy what we got a judge that going
on record here saying God is okay well
it gave people huh that's gonna be this
way more views yeah that's what I know
this a Hollywood the more support for
gays the more your loved
so I'm supporting gays a lot these days
yeah but not because they deserve you
know the same rights as everybody else
but basically thank you sure what they
are they really they really are awesome
that you know know yeah we should go to
a gay pride parade one day that'd be
cool I need to be so fun cool gonna be
in French is appealing yes decided for
you he'll get a suck his dick and you
think lesbians I don't know some listen
you know it's funny about lesbians to me
but you know how like some lesbians like
strap-ons oh and I think to myself you
like strap-ons but why don't you like a
penis like at all when a strap-on is
symbolizing a penis it's because it's a
tool I know not all lesbians like these
a stimulation to it
I see because it's not about what it
looks like is it's the function is what
a function over form see this is what
happens you ask questions you'll learn
there's a Learning Channel
yes that's what toc-toc is the learning
champion The Learning Channel TLC TLC
was like a rap group or something they
also I thought I meant tender loving
care
also yeah oh but when we're talking
about a TV TLC is Wow deals they give me
a lot of things yeah to love [ __ ]